What you're looking at right over here
are a bunch of my YouTube videos being
ingested into an LLM wiki. This LLM
wiki, as you can see if I zoom in, are
different YouTube videos and what's
connecting them are different relations.
So, we're starting to see this actual
kind of like second brain of all of my
YouTube videos and how they relate to
each other and all of this knowledge
makes my AI OS so much smarter. And the
coolest part about this is I didn't have
to connect these concepts at all. I was
able to just say, "Hey, Claude code, go
grab my YouTube videos and then ingest
them into this wiki." And this thing
continuously grows and grows. If I zoom
in a little bit, let's open up one of
these videos. So, right here I've got
Nano Banana two websites. When I open
this up, we can see some information up
here, but then as we scroll down, we can
see, you know, summary, key takeaways,
and other tools and things that are
mentioned and other techniques that have
been discussed. And I can follow all of
these links around. Let's say I'm
interested in GitHub. I can click on the
GitHub. I can see what this is about and
then I can see other times that we've
referenced GitHub. Here's some
information that connects GitHub to
Vercel. Why don't I click into that and
learn some more about Vercel? And then
Vercel can take me back to Claude code
where I once again can follow all of
these backlinks until I get to where I
need to go. And so, as this whole mind
map of these YouTube videos starts to
grow, we're able to see all of this come
to life. And today I'm going to show you
guys exactly how you can get up and
running with something just like this in
about 5 minutes. It's so much simpler
than you may think. Now, what's
impressive about this isn't the fact
that Fable was able to ingest all of it,
it's what Fable can do once you've given
it the power of all of this data cuz we
all know that data is king, context is
king. Here's a cool example. I asked
Fable in one prompt, I said, "Hey, I
want you to basically turn this messy
blob of YouTube transcripts connections
into something that people could
actually look at and understand. I want
this to be a simple resource that's not
overwhelming, but shows my audience how
these tools and techniques and ideas
connect to each other." And now we have
this super cool HTML which I can click
into and I can see different ideas up
top, agentic workflows and what it
connects to. It connects to routines.
Routines connects to deterministic
versus agentic automation which connects
back to N&N and Claude code and all of
this kind of stuff and it's just
amazing. In my mind, something like this
is a much more user-friendly interface
than something like this. And what I
think is awesome about this is that I
was able to prompt it in an emotional
way. I said things like, "In a way that
a beginner could understand and could
click through and it wouldn't overwhelm
them." And something like Opus 4.8 just
doesn't understand what that means as
well as Fable. To show you what I mean
by that, this is something that I worked
on with Opus 4 almost a full day. We
went back and forth, we built this thing
out, and I just didn't like it enough to
share it with people because it felt
overwhelming. It felt confusing. And the
database on the back end that powers
this is the exact same one. So anyways,
what we're looking for here is same
thing. You can search through tools,
techniques, videos. There's kind of like
a layer framework that we discussed with
the orchestrator, the models, the
inputs, all of this kind of stuff. And
it has all the same data, and I can
still click into these things, and I can
follow the back links, and you know,
it's kind of the same idea, but once
again, this version is just so much
simpler to me, and I like it more. You
can see as we click on a concept, we're
able to see on this right-hand side
videos that it pulled this data from. We
can read a little bit more about it, and
we can see what else it's connected to.
So that's just one very small example.
If you guys have been following me for a
while, you know that in my AIOS, I have
a few different LLM wikis. This is my
YouTube transcript one. I've also got
like my Herc brain one, which is pretty
much where I put all of my meeting
recordings. So all of my meetings,
whether they're internal or external, I
store them here, and that's how I'm able
to see how the different concepts that
I'm talking about with people have
evolved and how they are going to
continue to evolve. And when I'm
scripting community posts, LinkedIn
posts, writing emails, it takes all of
this stuff into account because it knows
everything about me and my business. So
much so that right before this video, I
said, "Hey, Mr. Fable, I want you to go
ahead and just tell me a story about the
past 6 months." So, you know, we're
halfway through 2026. Build me a visual
journey of what we've done so far in
2026. And this is what it gave me in one
shot. It was able to pull this picture
of me. It pulled our logo, and you can
see that this thing is even feel And you
can see that the branding of this even
feels like AIS. It's kind of dark mode,
blue graph colors, and this is what it
gave me. It pulled actual stats like how
many subscribers I gained. Um it has our
highest revenue month, which I'm going
to blur out, but it was able to look at
all this data and just pull it for me.
This was a big pivot I made this year. I
went from pretty much doing only
end-to-end content to doing a lot of
cloud code content. And you can see how
this was able to pay off if we look at
my average views and our revenue and how
the business has grown since I made that
pivot. Then we look at some other things
like how our churn has changed, how our
conversion has changed, other things
about our revenue. But look at this.
This is pretty funny. It pulled this
different picture of me. If you guys
remember the one up at the front was a
smiling one. This is one of me thinking.
And so it's able to just crawl through
so much of the data and the resources
that it has available inside of my Herk
2 project. It shows the whole funnel of
the business, which proves that it
understands how people enter our
ecosystem and all the decisions they can
make inside of our funnel and where we
try to push them to. Anyways, the point
I'm trying to make there is the more
data you give your projects, the better.
But specifically, making sure that you
route them in the right way. And that's
what the LLM Wiki's are really good at.
This is my Herk 2 project. You guys know
that this is my AIOS, and we have so
much information in here. We have
different wikis, different projects,
everything that I've worked on, and
that's what you guys are trying to
build. By the way, if you want to go
through a full free course where I show
you how to do that, in my free school
community, link is in the description,
I've got a full build your own AIOS
course in there, completely free. So,
link is in the description for that.
Okay. So, here's where all of this
started. Andre Karpathy said, "LLM
knowledge bases. Something I'm finding
very useful lately is using LLMs to
build personal knowledge bases for
various topics of research interest." He
index the sources, which I'm going to
show you how to do, and then he uses
something like Obsidian as the front
end, which is what you guys just saw.
So, the first thing you want to do is go
to obsidian.md and then install this for
whatever operating system you're on. So,
in my case, I installed this for
Windows, run the wizard, get it set up,
and open up the app. When you open up
the app, it will look like this, except
for you won't have this stuff, and then
you're going to go down here and click
on manage vaults. It might just pop up
like this. And then you're going to go
ahead and create a new vault. So, this
one I'm just going to call AI test, and
then you're going to choose a location
for this. So, it could be on your
desktop or what I typically like to do
is I put my vaults inside of my Herc 2
project. So, my Herc 2 is able to look
at a ton of these different little LLM
wikis that I have split up and separated
by topic essentially. But, for this
example, I'm just going to put this one
on my desktop. So, I'm going to go ahead
and create that wiki. You can see here
or sorry, not wiki, vault. We're going
to turn this into a wiki. So, right now
this is what we have and then what I'm
going to want you to do is you're going
to go into Claude code or wherever you
use Claude code. So, in this case, I'm
using VS Code and you're going to open
up that vault in something like this.
All right. So, I've just opened up the
vault. You can see that we have a dot
Obsidian folder. We have a welcome.md.
That's just going to be, you know, the
default when you open up an Obsidian
vault. And then what we're going to do
is open up Claude code. So, however you
like to use it, in VS Code I like to use
it in the terminal. So, I'm going to go
ahead and run Claude to open this up and
then we're going to go ahead and get
started. Now, one thing to call out here
is we see that it says, "Okay, Fable,
you only have it until July 7th on your
limit, otherwise it will be usage
credits." I did however see this tweet
from Thor that said, "Yeah, that's true,
but we do plan to bring it back to part
of your subscription as soon as
possible." As mentioned in our original
blog post, which if you see at the
bottom of this blog post, it does
actually mention that. So, it doesn't
say when, but hopefully they will be
able to extend the window and bring it
back as a standard part of your
subscription plan. Anyways, what you're
going to do after that is you're going
to go to this page. I will have this
link in the description. It is
Karpathy's LLM wiki gist and I'm
literally just going to copy this entire
thing. If you want to stop and read it,
feel free, but I'm going to copy this
entire thing and what we're going to do
is take that back into our Claude and
paste that in there. And then what
you're going to do is just go ahead and
take a screenshot of this so you can
paste it in. I said, "You are now my LLM
wiki agent. Implement this exact idea
file as my complete second brain. Guide
me step by step. Create the Claude.md
schema with my full rules. Set up the
index, the log, define folder
conventions, and show me the first
ingest example. From now on, every
interaction follows the schema." So, I'm
going to go ahead and send that off. We
are using Fable here. Like I said, you
probably don't need Fable. Fable's
probably overkill for this. It's about
what Fable does after you have all that
data in there. So, if you want to switch
this back to Opus, run the ingest, and
ingest future documents with Opus,
that's probably a better call, honestly.
I'm just going to be showing you Fable
in this video. Now, what's really cool
is as you start to put different stuff
in here, it's going to sort of
dynamically change the structure. So,
let me show you what I mean by that. If
I open up this wiki, you can see that in
the wiki I have comparisons, I have
concepts, I have sources, because this
one is about my YouTube videos. So, it's
read through them and it's analyzed
that. We've got techniques and we've got
tools. But, if I switch into something
like my Herc brain, which is the one
that's more so around like my meeting
transcripts, you can see that this is
pretty much a flat structure. It
basically just has all of my meeting
recordings right in here, and it didn't
want to organize them yet. And maybe at
some point if we run some, you know,
sweeps through, it will find some
different folders to organize them in.
But, sometimes keeping this flat is
actually better. And by flat what I mean
is basically just having everything in
the wiki, rather than having it drill
down to even more folders. The reason
being,
you want to make sure that your AI can
easily search through all this stuff. We
have the raw, which is where you put
stuff. Then the AI will read everything
in the raw and ingest it into the wiki,
and that's where it might take one
source and split it up into like five or
six, or maybe even 10 little wiki pages.
Then we also have the index, which is
like a table of contents. We have the
log, and then the dot md files are all
of the other wiki files. And this exact
structure is how this Herc brain one is
set up. As you can see, it's very flat.
But, if we go back into my YouTube
transcript one, this one's not flat,
right? This one has all of these other
subfolders, like we just talked about.
And to show you what that looks like in
this example, here is my index. You can
see all the tools, you can see all of
the uh techniques, everything that has
been mapped out here with all the
backlinks. And then the log, you can see
that I did a few batch ingests here.
I've done one there, and then every time
that I've ingested another YouTube video
or ingested other data sources, it will
show a log of that there. The whole
point of this is that the AI can
incrementally build and maintain this
wiki. So, it needs to be able to look at
things like the index and the logs and
all the backlinks to actually crawl
around and find the data that you're
looking for. All right, so now you can
see that this is done. Our project is
set up. We have our index, which is
blank. We have our log, which is pretty
much blank. And then we have our raw
folder and our wiki folder. So, what you
can see in here already is that in the
raw, it processed this LLM wiki idea.
This file is basically the gist that
Karpathy wrote up. So, it decided to
ingest that. And then in the wiki, it's
already planned out to have concepts,
entities, and sources. So, that is what
we have to start with. Now, what I want
to do is we're going to ingest two
different things and I'm going to show
you different ways you can do it. So,
the first thing that we're going to
ingest is the Claude Fable 5 and Mythos
5 system card. So, I'm going to go ahead
and download this as a PDF. What I'm
going to do is take this PDF and I'm
going to drag it into the raw. So, now
that PDF lives right there in the raw.
And then what I'm going to do is we're
going to take this OpenAI previewing
GPT-5.6 soul and we're going to just do
this as a URL instead. So, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to paste in the
URL and I'm going to say,
"Hey Claude,
read this article and then ingest that
into our wiki here. And then also, I
dropped in a PDF in the raw called
Claude Fable 5 and I want you to also
ingest that." And that is all that I'm
going to tell this model. Once again, it
should be understanding how this is set
up. We should see a new record in the
index as well as a new record in the log
and some new sources in the wiki. So,
whether Fable decides to turn this PDF
into one or five or maybe even 50 wiki
pages because of how big that PDF was,
same thing with the URL, I will let you
guys know when this finishes up.
Okay, so that finished up. It took about
10 to 12 minutes and you can see here
that out of those two sources, it
created 20 wiki pages and they're fully
cross-linked. Now, look at this. The
connection that made this worth having
as a wiki instead of two separate
summaries, the two sources reference
each other, and Frontier Model
Cybersecurity is where that lives.
OpenAI benchmarked GPT-5.6 Soul against
Mythos Preview, and I flagged the thing
easy to miss reading them separately.
OpenAI compared to the April
predecessor, not to Mythos 5, and the
two labs used different harnesses, so
the numbers don't line up directly. So,
anyways, let's go ahead and pull open
this wiki full screen and take a look.
Okay, so this is what it looks like. You
can see we've got OpenAI down here, and
these are the ones that it relates to,
like the
Claude code said, it referenced Claude
Mythos 5 in the article. So, that's
pretty cool. And we can see sort of the
distribution here. We can see how much
we've got things like
government-coordinated model releases.
We've got layered safeguards,
competitive use safeguards. And if we go
over here to the wiki, we can see that
we have concepts, we have entities, we
have sources, and then we have topics.
So, the entities is cool because in here
we have models. We've got Fable, Mythos,
Mythos Preview, Opus 4.8, GPT-5.6. We've
got Tropic and OpenAI. And then if we go
to the log, you can see this was the
initial setup, and then we had the
OpenAI article and the Claude Fable 5
system card. So, the lesson here is that
we now have this system where we have
Claude code that looks at a bunch of our
data sources, right? It looks at the
wiki, and it looks through potentially
multiple wikis. And inside the wiki,
what happens is there are routing rules
set up so that our agents are able to
figure out where to look for what
specific thing, like the data that it's
looking for, because it has to crawl
through basically all of this in an
efficient way, so it's not wasting our
time and our tokens to find the right
answer. And that theory is basically
what Claude code is. It's basically
figuring out how can my Claude at MD
work as a router to be able to look
through my past projects, to be able to
look through my business context, and
find the right spot. And so, from here,
once you've already started to get the
structure figured out, you're just going
to start adding more data sources, and
you're going to watch how this evolves,
and you're going to constantly check and
see if it all makes sense. Because if
you do a batch ingest, and you don't
like the way that it organized some of
these folders and files, then maybe you
go ahead and change it up a little bit.
You know, you start to open up these
pages like competitive use safeguards,
read about it, click through, and see if
it all still makes sense. And if you
don't like how things are happening,
then update the rules in the way that
you ingest. Like I said, every LLM wiki
that I've set up, they have different
structures and a little bit different
rules because of the type of data that's
in there. Whether that's meeting
transcripts or, you know, personal data
or, you know, proposals, whatever it is
that you're ingesting here, make it make
sense. Not only to the AI, but make it
make sense to you. The whole point is
that you could also go through this and
follow the chain and find what you're
looking for. And the greatest part about
all this is once you realize, "Oh, look,
everything in this wiki, it's just a
markdown file. It's just markdown files
with routing." That means you're not
locked down to using this only in cloud
code. You can connect your Hermes agent
to this. You can connect Codex to this.
You can connect whatever you want to
this because it's just markdown files.
And if you guys want to learn more about
the whole idea of like building a second
brain, then check out this video right
here where I go over every level of
building a second brain, and how you
know if you actually need to like move
up a little bit or move down a little
bit, and figure out what's right for you
and your system. So, anyways, thanks for
making it to the end of the video, and
I'll see you guys in the next one.
Thanks, guys.